um  try and build a streak  oh this opening again  ah it's slightly annoying  maybe it's okay just trade  it's scary because this alignment but  yeah i just lost a queen i have um  i have material for it  i want to play knight five i want to win  the pawn  so takes rook a4  i mean the the non-queen pieces work  together nicely  oh there's a funny line takes here here  sacked the rook and then made on a7  it might happen  so threatening the rook sack ah it's not  happening  i need to get the bishop here  hence why g4  and now i'm threatening the rook sack  let's go  so beautiful  i had the i had the idea  oh was there a prediction of whether i  would say there's a funny line  oh that's funny  yeah so i saw the idea i mean already in  this position like this is a  a very puzzle rush mating idea  puzzle store mating idea just had to  make it  become a reality